(HOST) IRA GLASS: Recently, I was talking to this guy who told me how years ago, because of a medical condition, he had to give up beer. He had only been a casual beer drinker before this. He'd never really given beer much thought. But now that he couldn't have a beer, he was thinking of beer all the time. He had a fantasy. It went like this. He goes into a bar, and he orders a beer. That was the whole thing. It's hard giving things up.
（主持人）艾拉·格拉斯：最近，我和一个人聊天，他告诉我多年前，因为某种疾病，他不得不戒掉啤酒。在那之前，他只是偶尔喝点啤酒。他以前从未真正考虑过啤酒的问题。但现在他喝不了啤酒了，却满脑子都是啤酒。他产生了一个幻想。是这样的：他走进一家酒吧，点了一杯啤酒。事情就是这样。放弃一些东西是很难的。
Walter was three, and it was time for him to give up the pacifier. The pacifier was impairing his speech, and so it was time to give it up. And his mom and dad weaned him from it slowly. At first, he could only use the pacifier upstairs, then only upstairs in his room, then only upstairs in his room in the bed, though enforcement on the whole bed thing was actually kind of spotty.
沃尔特三岁了，是时候让他戒掉奶嘴了。奶嘴影响了他的说话，所以是时候戒掉了。他的爸爸妈妈慢慢地让他断掉奶嘴。起初，他只能在楼上用奶嘴，后来只能在楼上的房间里用，再后来只能在楼上房间的床上用，尽管执行起来其实有点松懈。
Anyway, finally came the big day. Walter announced he was ready to get rid of the pacifier. And he threw it into the trash himself. And everybody clapped, and everybody hugged him. And then the drove to a toy store, and they got him some special presents, a toy treehouse, a teddy bear.
总之，大日子终于到了。沃尔特宣布他准备好丢掉奶嘴了。他自己把它扔进了垃圾桶。大家都鼓掌，大家都拥抱他。然后他们开车去了一家玩具店，给他买了一些特别的礼物，一个玩具树屋，一只泰迪熊。
And that first night, when it was time to sleep, Walter was brave. He was stoic. He went right to bed. And maybe, I don't know, five minutes passed before he was out of the bedroom and downstairs crying. "I'm really sad," he said. His mom and dad asked him if he wanted to play with his new toys for a while. And he tried that, and then went back to bed.
第一天晚上，睡觉的时候，沃尔特很勇敢。他表现得很坚强。他直接上床睡觉了。然后，我不确定，可能过了五分钟，他就从卧室出来，下楼哭了。“我真的很伤心，”他说。他的爸爸妈妈问他想不想玩一会儿新玩具。他试了一下，然后又回床上去了。
More sobbing. An hour passes, two hours. It breaks his parents' hearts. Frankly, if they still had had the pacifier in the house, they would have caved and given it to him, it was so upsetting. But he had thrown into the trash at his grandparents' house. It was gone.
更多的啜泣。一小时过去了，两小时过去了。这让他的父母心碎。坦白说，如果他们家里还有奶嘴的话，他们肯定会屈服并给他的，这太让人难受了。但他已经在祖父母家把它扔进垃圾桶了。它不见了。
And that night, for the first time in his life, Walter slept in his parents' bed. It was the only way that he could actually get to sleep. The next night was a little easier, next a little easier than that. Anyway, after a couple of days, Walter announced the special request that he had for all the grown-ups in his life, grandmas, grandpas, uncles and aunts, the lady next door. He wanted to hear their stories about when they gave up their pacifiers.
那天晚上，沃尔特有生以来第一次睡在父母的床上。这是他能真正入睡的唯一方法。第二天晚上容易了一些，再往后也容易了一些。总之，几天后，沃尔特宣布了他对生活中所有成年人的特别要求，包括奶奶、爷爷、叔叔阿姨、隔壁的阿姨。他想听听他们当年戒掉奶嘴的故事。
I told this to a friend of mine who gave up drinking a decade ago, how this little boy, Walter, wanted to hear these stories. And she said, man, that's just like AA. Though the problem for Walter, of course, was that no adult really remembers giving up their own pacifier. It's just too long ago, right? So everybody either talked about giving up other stuff that the did remember, like giving up their blankets as little kids. One auntie offered to talk to him about how she quit smoking, but she was warned off that. Or they just made up stories, dramatic stories about giving up their pacifiers to tell Walter.
我把这件事告诉了一个十年前戒酒的朋友，告诉她这个叫沃尔特的小男孩想听这些故事。她说，伙计，这就像匿名戒酒互助会（AA）。当然，沃尔特的问题在于，没有成年人真的记得自己戒掉奶嘴的时候了。那已经是太久以前的事了，对吧？所以大家都要么谈论自己记得的其他东西，比如小时候戒掉毯子。有一位阿姨主动提出告诉他自己是如何戒烟的，但被制止了。或者，他们只是编造故事，编造关于戒掉奶嘴的戏剧性故事讲给沃尔特听。
It's comforting to hear other people's stories of kicking the habit. It's just comforting at any age. It makes it feel like it's possible. And so, this week we bring you four stories of people giving things up, living without, some of them voluntarily, some not.
听到别人戒掉习惯的故事是令人欣慰的。无论在什么年纪，这都是令人欣慰的。它让人觉得这是可能的。所以，本周我们为大家带来四个关于人们放弃某些东西、没有那些东西生活的报道，有些是自愿的，有些则不是。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Act One of our program today, Do You Hear What I Hear? In that act, one man, one teenage daughter, and many, many fish. Act Two, The Journalism of Deprivation, Sarah Vowell introduces you to a magazine that, if you're lucky, you have never had to read. Act Three, The Call of the Great Indoors, in which we hear a defense of living inside from somebody who can speak authoritatively about the pros and cons. Act Four, Tin Man. In that act, life without a heart. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天节目的第一幕，你听到了吗？在这一幕中，一个男人，一个十几岁的女儿，还有许多许多的鱼。第二幕，匮乏的新闻报道，莎拉·沃威尔带你认识一本如果你幸运的话，从来不需要阅读的杂志。第三幕，伟大的室内生活，在这一幕中，我们听到一位能权威地讲述其利弊的人为室内生活进行的辩护。第四幕，铁皮人。在这一幕中，没有心的生活。请继续收听。
Act One, Do You Hear What I Hear? This is a story of being forced to give one thing and then giving up another by choice. Nubar Alexanian put it together with his daughter Abby.
第一幕，你听到了吗？这是一个关于被迫放弃一件事，然后选择放弃另一件事的故事。努巴尔·亚历山大和他女儿艾比一起制作了这个节目。
(HOST) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: You know, I didn't talk about it for a long time, because it's so abstract. It's like people can't imagine it.
（主持人）努巴尔·亚历山大：你知道，我很久没谈论过这件事，因为它太抽象了。就像人们无法想象它一样。
[RINGING NOISE]
（铃声）
But then, I'll be in a restaurant. There's a loud din of people talking, and dishes, and all that stuff going on in a restaurant, and somebody will ask me, well, how loud is it right now? And I'll often say, it's the loudest thing in the room. And people can't-- it's just incomprehensible to people that you could get used to a tone like that in your head all the time. See, as I'm talking about it right now, it's really loud.
但后来，我会在餐馆里。餐馆里有人们交谈、碗碟碰撞等等各种嘈杂声，有人会问我，现在有多吵？我通常会说，这是房间里最吵的东西。人们无法——人们根本无法理解你竟然能习惯脑子里一直有那样的声音。你看，就像我现在在谈论它时一样，它真的很响。
[RINGING NOISE]
（铃声）
The very first doctor I saw was this young ear, nose, and throat guy. And he examined me. But he was examining me as if he were just going through the motions. He already knew what he was going to tell me. so after all the examinations, he said, well, you have tinnitus. And there's no cure for it. You're just going to have to learn to live with it.
我见过的第一位医生是个年轻的耳鼻喉科医生。他给我检查了。但他检查的时候就像在走过场。他已经知道他要告诉我什么了。所以检查完之后，他说，嗯，你患了耳鸣。这没法治。你只能学会与它共存。
[WHISTLING NOISE]
（哨声）
And I thought, well, what are you talking about? I can't learn to live with this. And I went through 10 years of-- five other doctors-- going to the high priests at Boston Hospital, to every alternative psychic-- thing you can possibly imagine. There's an-- four or five different acupuncturists. This one dentist said, well, I'm going to make you a mouth guard. He said, well, I'm sure this will work. It's going to cost you $19,000. And I did some muscle body work and some homeopathic remedies. I had my entire jaw realigned by a dentist over a two-year period. And we had things like this guy come in who spread these Petri dishes all over our house. So we had to install all these filtering systems in our house, and fans, and air cleaners and dehumidifiers. So I've spent probably over 10 years, $70,000.
我想，你到底在说什么？我没法学会与此共存。我经历了10年的——另外5位医生——去看波士顿医院的顶级专家，去看每一个你能想象到的替代疗法、灵学之类的东西。有——四五位不同的针灸师。这位牙医说，好吧，我要给你做一个护齿。他说，我肯定这会有用的。它要花你19000美元。我做了肌肉按摩和一些顺势疗法。我让牙医在两年内重整了我的整个下巴。我们还有人像这家伙一样进来，把这些培养皿撒满我们的房子。所以我们不得不在房子里安装所有这些过滤系统，还有风扇、空气净化器和除湿机。所以我大概花了10多年，7万多美元。
I'm a photographer. And the first tone appeared around the same time that I started working on this book about musicians called Where Music Comes From. And I traveled around the world with 25 different musicians. And all of a sudden, I had to stop.
我是个摄影师。第一个声音出现的时候，大约是我开始制作那本名为《音乐从哪里来》的音乐家书籍的时候。我带着25位不同的音乐家周游世界。突然之间，我不得不停下来。
The first tone appeared at the beginning of the project. And then the second tone came. The whole thing got so bad that my career just came to a stop. I just couldn't travel. I was completely disabled by these tones.
第一个声音出现在项目开始时。然后第二个声音来了。整个事情变得太糟糕了，我的职业生涯就此中断。我根本无法旅行。这些声音让我完全丧失了工作能力。
I'm going to try on the piano. I think what I have in my right ear is a D-flat.
我要在钢琴上试一下。我想我右耳里的是降D音。
[PLAYING PIANO]
（弹钢琴）
And in my left ear, a C one octave lower.
在我左耳里，是低一个八度的C音。
[PLAYING PIANO]
（弹钢琴）
The right ear is a D-flat, and the left ear is a C. The most maddening part of this was when I was with this friend of mine, this jazz musician. And I described it to him. And he threw his head down on his hands on the table. We were having lunch. And I could see in him that he completely understood how maddening it was. Because he understood that the D-flat was always trying to resolve itself into the C.
右耳是降D，左耳是C。最让人抓狂的是当我和我这位朋友、一位爵士音乐家在一起的时候。我向他描述了它。他把头埋在桌上的双手里。我们当时正在吃午饭。我能看出他完全理解这有多抓狂。因为他明白降D总是试图自行解决到C音。
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: So can you play both of them at the same time?
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：那你能不能同时弹奏它们？
I might be able to. Let's see. Let me try this for a second.
我或许可以。看看吧。让我试一下。
[TONES]
（音调）
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: Dad?
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：爸爸？
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: Test. OK, what were you saying?
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：测试。好的，你刚才说什么？
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: That, well, as we've been doing this piece, I've been thinking, it must-- I can't imagine having a tone in my ear, especially like a pure tone, tones that don't stop like that. So I can not even imagine what it must be like to have it all the time.
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：就是，嗯，在我们制作这个节目的时候，我一直在想，这一定——我无法想象耳朵里一直有个声音，尤其是那种纯音，那种不会停下来的声音。所以我甚至无法想象一直带着它是什么感觉。
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: So what is it about having the tone?
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：那带着这种声音是什么感觉？
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: Like you're trapped inside your own head. You're in a room with no doors and no windows, and just a speaker of that sound driving you literally up the walls. I swear I would cut my head off or something. I'd follow van Gogh's path and cut my ears off.
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：就像被困在自己的脑袋里。你待在一个没有门没有窗的房间里，只有一个发出那种声音的扬声器，真的会把你逼疯。我发誓我会砍掉自己的头什么的。我会走梵高的老路，把自己的耳朵割掉。
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: This is an odd thing to say, I think. I'm somewhat grateful for the tone. Of course, I don't feel grateful on bad days. But before you were born, I used to travel constantly on assignment all over the world. And on good days, when I think about it, I think about the tone being a warning that I needed to slow down. And then you were born, and I thought, not only did I need to slow down, but I wanted to slow down.
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：我觉得这是一个奇怪的说法。我甚至有点感激这个声音。当然，在糟糕的日子里我并不觉得感激。但在你出生之前，我经常为了任务在世界各地奔波。在心情好的时候，当我想起这件事，我会觉得这个声音是一个警告，提醒我需要慢下来。然后你出生了，我想，我不仅需要慢下来，而且我也想要慢下来。
And on bad days, I feel like oh, OK, I've learned this lesson. I've slowed down. Now the tone can go away. But it doesn't go away.
而在糟糕的日子里，我会觉得哦，好的，我吸取了这个教训。我已经慢下来了。现在这个声音可以消失了。但它并没有消失。
[TONE]
（音调）
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: I'm reading through this outline of all the tapes that we have, and you say, I could not imagine losing my hearing. And I was like, well, wait a minute, it's not that bad. And then, I realize it's sort of the reverse. I haven't really lived with perfect hearing ever, so I can't compare. But I just thought it was interesting that you couldn't imagine losing your hearing, and I could not imagine having tinnitus.
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：我正在阅读我们所有录音的大纲，你说，我无法想象失去听力。我当时想，好吧，等一下，还没那么糟。然后，我意识到这有点相反。我从来没有过完美的听力，所以我无法比较。但我只是觉得有趣，你无法想象失去听力，而我无法想象患有耳鸣。
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: Do you remember when you got your hearing aid?
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：你还记得你什么时候戴上助听器的吗？
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: No.
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：不记得。
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: Do you want to hear what happened?
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：想听听当时发生了什么吗？
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: OK.
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：好的。
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: Because for Mom and I, it was a huge event. Because you'd gone through all the tests. And we discovered that you indeed had a hearing loss, and that they were going to fit you with a hearing aid. And before that, you kept saying "what" all the time. And there were certain words that you couldn't pronounce, or certain sounds that you obviously were missing. And that's what the audiologist and the doctors described to us.
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：因为对我和你妈妈来说，那是一件大事。因为你经历了所有的测试。我们发现你确实有听力损失，他们打算给你配助听器。在那之前，你总是说“什么”。有些词你发不出音，或者有些声音你明显错过了。这就是听力学家和医生描述给我们的情况。
So we went down to the Beverly Hospital. Your mom and I were sitting in the room. And she put the hearing aid in your ear and turned it on and made all the adjustments. And then you slid off the chair and said, oh my God. I can hear.
所以我们去了贝弗利医院。我和你妈妈坐在房间里。她把助听器戴在你的耳朵上，打开开关，做了所有的调整。然后你从椅子上滑下来，说，天哪。我能听到了。
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: Well, sometimes, I wonder what it would be like to hear everything perfectly. You know? To have that entire sound, every aspect of someone's voice, or music, every note, to hear every single one, would be incredible to me. And I don't know what that would be like. I've never known what that would be like.
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：嗯，有时我会想如果能完美地听到一切会是什么感觉。你知道吗？拥有那种完整的声音，人声的每一个方面，或者音乐，每一个音符，如果能听到每一个音符，那对我来说将是不可思议的。我不知道那是什么感觉。我从来没体会过。
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: Let's just talk about, you transcribed my hearing test, where you got to actually hear the sound that's in my ear.
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：我们来谈谈你整理我的听力测试的那部分，你当时真正听到了我耳朵里的那个声音。
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: I can't hear one of the tones that you ear.
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：我听不到你耳朵里的其中一个声音。
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: So you didn't hear the tone in my right ear?
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：所以你没听到我右耳的声音？
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: No, I couldn't hear the high one, because I'm missing that. That's part of my hearing loss. I'm missing that particular frequency in both my ears.
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：没，我听不到高音，因为我缺了那个频率。那是我的听力损失的一部分。我在双耳中都缺失了那个特定的频率。
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: So you can't hear the sound--
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：所以你听不到我听到的声音——
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: I can't hear the sound that you hear all the time.
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：我听不到你一直听到的那个声音。
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: At all.
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：完全听不到。
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: At all.
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：完全听不到。
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: That's incredible, though, don't you think?
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：但你不觉得这很不可思议吗？
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: I don't know. It's too much of a coincidence.
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：我不知道。这太巧合了。
(HOST) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: I can't be in quiet places. It can be really maddening to be in quite places. It's the thing, though, that I think is responsible for me taking up fly-fishing, because it's the closest I can get to quiet.
（主持人）努巴尔·亚历山大：我没法待在安静的地方。待在安静的地方真的会让人抓狂。不过，我想这就是我开始练习飞钓的原因，因为它是我能得到的最接近安静的状态。
I'm out there. It's early morning. It's dark. I'm in my boat. I push off into the current, don't start the engine. The river is waking up, and there are little sounds of birds and stuff going on.
我在那里。那是清晨。天还没亮。我在船上。我划进水流，不开引擎。河流正在苏醒，有鸟鸣等各种细小的声音。
And then there's me with my fly line going back and forth and back and forth. And I'm focusing on the fly line, trying to get it out 100 feet. And there's a sound that it makes that I can attach to. And so I'm really focused on that. And it takes me away from the sound in my head. And that's what quiet is to me. That's the most quiet that I can have.
然后就是我带着钓线来回甩动，来回甩动。我专注于飞钓线，努力把它甩出100英尺远。它发出的声音是我可以依附的。所以我非常专注。这把我从脑子里的声音中带离。这就是我所谓的安静。这是我能拥有的最彻底的安静。
(INTERVIEWER) NUBAR ALEXANIAN: Anything else you want to say about it?
（采访者）努巴尔·亚历山大：还有什么想说的吗？
(SUBJECT) ABBY ALEXANIAN: Just that I think, maybe it's taught you patience. Because I didn't know you before you had this, so I wouldn't know. But I would think that it might have taught you something about settling or acceptance.
（受访者）艾比·亚历山大：只是觉得，也许它教会了你耐心。因为在你拥有这个症状之前我不认识你，所以我不知道。但我认为它可能教会了你关于妥协或接受的东西。
Because I remember you told us a story about how you went to all these doctors. But the first doctor you went to told you there was no cure. You couldn't do anything. And so you spent tons of money seeing a whole bunch of other doctors who tried a whole bunch of other things. And finally, you just realized that the first doctor was right.
因为我记得你给我们讲过你去看所有这些医生的故事。但你去看的第一位医生告诉你没有治愈方法。你什么也做不了。于是你花了大笔钱去看其他医生，尝试了各种各样的方法。最后，你意识到第一位医生是对的。
And I guess that was probably your acceptance part of it. And it's also that you were working so frantically before. And then you got tinnitus, and you had to stop. And I got more of you.
我想那就是你接受它的部分。而且你之前工作太狂热了。后来你得了耳鸣，不得不停下来。而我得到了更多的你。
Because I do remember you traveling a lot. And I remember how much you were gone. And I remember asking Mom when you'd come home. But then you came home, and you stayed home. And you played with me. You took me to school every day. And I think that was really good for the family.
因为我确实记得你经常出差。我记得你有多少时间不在家。我记得曾问过妈妈你什么时候回来。但后来你回来了，你就留在家里了。你陪我玩。你每天带我上学。我想这对我们家庭真的很好。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Nubar and Abby Alexonian. They put together that story with Jay Allison for the website transom.org. If you want to learn how to put together a radio story, they explain how to do it at transom.org. Their story got funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
（主持人）艾拉·格拉斯：努巴尔和艾比·亚历山大。他们和杰·艾利森一起为 transom.org 网站制作了这个故事。如果你想学习如何制作广播故事，他们在那上面解释了如何操作。他们的故事获得了公共广播公司（CPB）的资助。
Act Two, The Journalism of Deprivation. Our program today is all about doing without this or that. And our contributing editor, Sarah Vowell, brings us this report on a publication that she's read a bit of lately.
第二幕，匮乏的新闻报道。我们今天的节目都是关于没有这个或那个的。我们的特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔给我们带来了关于她最近读到的一本出版物的报道。
(HOST) SARAH VOWELL: The names of certain magazines are supposed to cheer a person up, Glamour, Lucky, Gourmet, Allure. Life, these titles suggest, is full of possibilities. Then, there's the magazine I read. This magazine has the most downbeat name of any magazine since DownBeat. It is called Living Without. Living Without bills itself as a lifestyle guide for people with allergies and food sensitivities, which sounds straightforward enough. But the name Living Without is so depressing, so forlorn, such a belligerent refusal to accentuate the positive, that I don't know why its publishers don't just come clean and call it Loser.
（主持人）莎拉·沃威尔：某些杂志的名字本应让人高兴，比如《魅力》、《幸运》、《美食》、《诱惑》。这些标题暗示着生活充满了可能性。然后，还有我读的那本杂志。这本杂志的名字比《DownBeat》（爵士乐评论杂志）之后任何一本杂志的名字都要消沉。它叫《Living Without》（没有……的生活）。《Living Without》宣称自己是为有过敏和食物敏感的人准备的生活指南，这听起来够直接了。但《Living Without》这个名字太压抑，太凄凉，是对强调积极面的一种如此好战的拒绝，我不知道为什么它的出版商不干脆坦白点，直接叫它《失败者》。
I read Living Without because I actually do live without. I'm allergic to wheat. On the one hand, this is a fairly serious problem. I'm always one bagel away from this panicky feeling of drowning. My throat closes up, and I'm hit with nausea that seems to affect every part of me, as if my fingers and ears want to throw up. On the other hand, nobody wants to hear about a disease whose treatment consists of scrutinizing food labels and never leaving the house without a fruit snack.
我读《Living Without》是因为我确实在过着“没有”的生活。我对小麦过敏。一方面，这是一个相当严重的问题。我总是离那种窒息恐慌感只有一个百吉饼的距离。我的喉咙会闭上，我会感到一阵恶心，这似乎影响到了我的每一个部分，好像我的手指和耳朵都想呕吐。另一方面，没有人想听一种治疗方法就是仔细检查食品标签，而且没带零食水果绝不出门的疾病。
Living Without is a magazine that revels in the mundane details of my condition. My favorite regular feature in Living Without is the column "Perils in the Pantry," which reads like a particularly over-the-top episode of The Munsters. Just as in the Munsters' upside-down world, in which the pretty, blonde cousin is pitied for her ugliness, in "Perils in the Pantry," supposedly cheerful events like parties and picnics are treated like the death traps they are.
《Living Without》是一本沉迷于我这种病症世俗细节的杂志。《Living Without》里我最喜欢的固定栏目是“食品储藏室里的危险”，读起来就像《亚当斯一家》（The Munsters）中情节特别夸张的一集。正如在亚当斯一家颠倒的世界里，漂亮的表妹因为她的丑陋而被同情一样，在“食品储藏室里的危险”中，派对和野餐这些理应欢乐的事件被视为致命的陷阱。
Beware of summertime salads, the column warns. Lurking under seemingly innocent lettuce, deadly croutons. "Perils at the Party" tells the horror story of one German-themed dinner party in which the entire meal consisted of wiener schnitzel, caraway noodles, and bread, or, as the wheat-sensitive might look upon the table, meat dusted with wheat, rectangular glops of wheat, and baked wheat. The author's advice? Before going out to a dinner party, eat first.
栏目警告说，提防夏季沙拉。在看似无辜的生菜下，潜伏着致命的面包丁。“派对上的危险”讲述了一个德式主题晚宴的恐怖故事，整顿饭包括维也纳炸牛排、葛缕子面条和面包，或者，用对小麦过敏的人眼中的话来说，裹着小麦粉的肉、块状的小麦制品，还有烤小麦。作者的建议？在去参加晚宴之前，先吃饱。
Living Without featured one article about a family who had switched religions in search of a house of worship that provided a gluten-free communion wafer. And the greatest election story in recent times? Not the Florida recount, in Living Without. In Living Without the juiciest event in recent electoral politics was the 1998 race for lieutenant governor of Massachusetts, in which both the Republican and Democratic candidates were allergic to wheat.
《Living Without》有一篇文章写了一个家庭为了寻找能提供无麸质圣餐饼的教堂而改信了宗教。而近期最棒的选举故事？不是佛罗里达州的重新计票，而是在《Living Without》里。在《Living Without》看来，近期选举政治中最劲爆的事件是1998年马萨诸塞州副州长的竞选，共和党和民主党的候选人居然都对小麦过敏。
Living Without makes me feel less alone, less of an oddball. I don't have any wheat-free friends. And since I hope to hang on to the friends I do have, I try and spare them the nitty-gritty details. Not to mention that most of them have an underwhelming grasp of the pros and cons of various brands of soy flour. My friend, Nick, was perplexed when the last time we had breakfast together, I asked the waitress if I could have a banana instead of toast. When I asked Nick about it later, he said, "A banana instead of toast? Why not ask for anything, then, anything of a similar monetary value to toast, like a cassette tape?"
《Living Without》让我感觉不那么孤独，不那么像个怪胎。我没有小麦过敏的朋友。既然我希望能留住现有的朋友，我就尽量不告诉他们这些琐碎的细节。更不用说他们大多数人对各种品牌大豆粉的利弊了解甚少。我朋友尼克上次我们一起吃早餐时感到困惑，当时我问服务员能不能给我一个香蕉代替吐司。后来我问尼克时，他说：“吐司换成香蕉？那为什么不干脆要点别的呢，要点跟吐司价值相近的东西，比如一盘磁带？”
At least I didn't find out I was sensitive to wheat gluten until I was over 30. The real heartbreakers in Living Without involve allergic kids and the terrified parents who love them. Mostly, it's one sob story after another, the boy who accidentally bit into a peanut butter cookie and died, the family of a first grader who spent part of their summer vacation at diabetes camp, mothers who write sentences such as, "My heart sank," or "I was standing right next to him when he ate that cookie, and I couldn't save him."
至少我三十多岁时才发现自己对小麦麸质敏感。《Living Without》里真正让人心碎的是那些过敏的孩子以及爱他们的惊恐万状的父母。大部分是一个接一个的悲惨故事，比如误咬了一口花生酱曲奇而死亡的男孩，在糖尿病营度过暑假一部分时间的五年级学生家庭，那些写下如“我的心沉了下去”或“他吃那个曲奇的时候我就站在他旁边，但我却救不了他”等句子的母亲们。
Still, one of my favorite things I've read in Living Without was written by the mother of a gluten-allergic son. Once a week, family night in their household was called pizza night. And they would all go out for pizza, until young Alec was diagnosed. They thought pizza night was history, until the mother finally figured out that she could just bring gluten-free dough to the pizzeria. All happy endings in Living Without are like this. Even the triumphs involve minor indignities like schlepping your own crust in tinfoil when going out for dinner.
不过，我在《Living Without》里读到的最喜欢的东西之一是一位麸质过敏儿的母亲写的。每周一次，他们家的家庭之夜叫披萨之夜。他们以前都会出去吃披萨，直到小亚历克被诊断出来。他们以为披萨之夜成了历史，直到那位母亲终于想出她可以自带无麸质面团去披萨店。《Living Without》里所有的圆满结局都是这样的。即使是胜利也涉及像出门吃饭时要用锡箔纸包着自己的面皮这样的轻微侮辱。
The earnestness of this story, of everything in Living Without , is the main reason I find it so reassuring. There are headlines that would seem ridiculous in any other magazine, an article on gluten-free weddings called "Have Your Cake," a guide to international cuisine called, "The World is Your Rice Noodle," that concludes with the thought, "Bye-bye, American pie, hello, pad Thai." It's corny, but that's kind of what I like about it.
这个故事，以及《Living Without》中一切内容的真诚，是我觉得它如此令人安心的主要原因。有些标题在任何其他杂志里看起来都会很可笑，一篇关于无麸质婚礼的文章叫“吃掉你的蛋糕”，一份国际美食指南叫“世界就是你的米粉”，结尾还感叹道：“再见，美国派，你好，泰式炒河粉。”这很俗气，但这正是我喜欢它的原因。
If the information in Living Without were conveyed more clinically in the dignified style of, say, the New York Times , the information would feel less welcoming. And it would also feel less true. There's nothing dignified about being allergic to wheat. It's the kind of annoying, specific, picky food nuisance you can only really talk about with the one person on earth who truly gives a hoot what kind of cracker you'd prefer, your mom. The corniness of Living Without is so comforting because it feels so maternal, as if it's written by a gaggle of friendly, Midwestern mothers, whose warm, cheerful kitchens smell like fresh-baked bread, fresh-baked bread made out of rice flour and potato starch.
如果《Living Without》中的信息以更临床、更庄重的风格（比如《纽约时报》的风格）传达出来，这些信息会让人感觉没那么亲切。而且也会感觉没那么真实。对小麦过敏没什么庄重可言。这是一种令人恼火、具体、挑剔的食物麻烦，你只能真正与地球上那个唯一在乎你想吃哪种饼干的人——你的妈妈——谈论这些。 《Living Without》的俗气让人如此安慰，因为它感觉如此母性，仿佛它是被一群友好的、中西部的妈妈们写的，她们温暖而快乐的厨房里飘散着新鲜出炉的面包味——用米粉和土豆淀粉制成的新鲜面包。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Sarah Vowell is the author of a number of books, most recently Assassination Vacation . Her story is part of a project at hearingvoices.com, which gets funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
（主持人）艾拉·格拉斯：莎拉·沃威尔是多本书的作者，最近的作品是《刺杀度假》。她的故事是 hearingvoices.com 项目的一部分，该项目获得了公共广播公司的资助。
[MUSIC - "WITHOUT YOU" BY MARIAH CAREY]
（音乐 - 玛丽亚·凯莉的“Without You”）
Act Three, The Call of the Great Indoors. There are some kinds of living without that is really hard for most of us to fathom. In Boston, Chelsea Merz has been talking with somebody about one of those.
第三幕，伟大的室内生活。有些“没有”的生活方式是我们大多数人真的很难理解的。在波士顿，切尔西·默兹一直在和某人谈论这些事。
(HOST) CHELSEA MERZ: The first thing I noticed about Matthew were his fingernails. They're so clean, much cleaner than mine. And I am humbled. I have no excuse. Unlike Matthew, I have not been living on the streets for seven years.
（主持人）切尔西·默兹：我注意到马修的第一件事是他的指甲。它们太干净了，比我的干净得多。我感到羞愧。我没借口。不像马修，我并没有流落街头七年。
Every Saturday, we meet for lunch at Bertucci's, which is this family-style Italian restaurant. Every week, we sit at the same table. And every time, our waitress assures us that we've made it in time for the lunch special. We will get free refills on soft drinks, a complimentary garden salad, and a basket of rolls.
每周六，我们都在Bertucci's吃午餐，这是一家家庭式意大利餐厅。每周我们都坐在同一张桌子旁。每一次，服务员都会向我们保证我们在午餐特惠结束前赶到了。我们可以免费续杯软饮，一份免费的田园沙拉，还有一篮餐前面包卷。
One time, Matthew showed up 20 minutes late, and the manager was giving him a hard time. He was saying, you better make it up to her and buy lunch today. And when we got to our table, Matthew was laughing. And he said, he doesn't know I'm homeless. He has no idea.
有一次，马修迟到了20分钟，经理在刁难他。他说，你最好补偿一下，今天请客吃午餐。当我们坐下时，马修在笑。他说，他不知道我是无家可归的。他根本没想法。
And even though Matthew is carrying a large cardboard box, a messenger bag, and two book bags, he looks more like a college professor. He's clean. He's tidy. He's organized. He's incredibly polite. Every week, Matthew tells these stories. So every week, I record him.
尽管马修背着一个大纸箱、一个信使包和两个书包，但他看起来更像是一位大学教授。他很干净。他很整洁。他很有条理。他非常有礼貌。每周，马修都会讲这些故事。所以每周，我都录下他讲的话。
There was this time it rained nonstop. When that happens, the shelters just fill up. And there were 10 of us waiting for two hours. Eventually, people start talking.
有一次雨下个不停。这种情况发生时，避难所就满了。我们有十个人等了两个小时。最后，大家开始交谈。
Oh, where were you yesterday when it started raining? Oh, I was over here. Did you get in somewhere last night? No, I was outside, or I went under a bridge, or I, you know. So everybody's talking about these things. And one guy in the room was very quiet.
哦，昨天开始下雨的时候你在哪？哦，我在这儿。昨晚你有地方待吗？没有，我在外面，或者我躲在桥下，或者，你知道的。所以大家都在谈论这些事情。房间里有一个人非常安静。
Someone started talking. What'd you do? What'd you do yesterday? With this very thick Spanish accent, doesn't speak English very well, he told us he didn't know Boston at all. He had just arrived from New York. Didn't know the streets, didn't know where to go.
有人开始说话。你做什么了？你昨天做什么了？带着浓重的西班牙口音，英语说得不好，他告诉我们他根本不认识波士顿。他刚从纽约来。不知道街道，不知道去哪里。
And when it came time, what about you, where did you stay? Alley. Alley? Where were you? The alley? Oh, just right, right, the next block. Yeah, one block, one block. You only got as far as one block, and you went into the alley. Si, si.
轮到他时，你呢，你待在哪？巷子。巷子？你在哪？那个巷子？哦，就在，就在，隔壁街。是的，一条街，一条街。你只走了一条街，就进巷子了。是，是。
Oh, wow. So where'd you sleep in the alley? Was there any place you could sleep underneath or something? He said something like box. Box? You slept in a box? Si, si. What, a cardboard box? Wouldn't it be soaking wet? No, not cardboard. Metal, metal. Metal?
哦，哇。那你睡在巷子里哪？有什么可以睡在下面的地方之类的吗？他说了一些像箱子之类的词。箱子？你睡在箱子里？是，是。什么，纸箱吗？不会湿透吗？不，不是纸箱。金属，金属。金属？
You slept in a metal box? What are you-- and someone said, oh, a dumpster. You slept in a dumpster. No, no. Did you get any sleep? No, no, no sleep, because of afraid. Afraid? You were afraid? Si, senor.
你睡在金属箱里？你在说什么——有人说，哦，垃圾桶。你睡在垃圾桶里。不，不。你有睡着吗？没有，没有，没有睡觉，因为害怕。害怕？你很害怕？是，先生。
What were you afraid of? Somebody might come and beat you up or mug you? No, button. I said, button?
你怕什么？有人可能会来打你或者抢劫你？不，按钮。我说，按钮？
And all the sudden, it occurred to me. Oh, you didn't sleep in a dumpster, you slept in a trash compactor. Si, si. You were afraid somebody was going to come and maybe push a button. Si, si. When I heard that, it was like at a new level in my feelings and understanding of this whole thing. And you're afraid somebody might come to push the button and die a horrible death.
突然间，我明白了。哦，你不是睡在垃圾桶里，你睡在垃圾压缩机里。是，是。你怕有人会来按那个按钮。是，是。当我听到这个，我感觉我对这件事的感受和理解达到了一个新的高度。你怕有人会来按那个按钮然后惨死。
(HOST) CHELSEA MERZ: Once or twice a year, he gets to house-sit for an old friend. Around Christmas, he got an offer to house-sit for more than two weeks. I met him for lunch the day that ended, and he was back on the street. I wanted to know what it was for him to have a comfortable place to sleep for a change. Usually, he can't count on any of his regular spots. And sometimes, he has to stay up all night in a Kinko's or Dunkin' Donuts.
（主持人）切尔西·默兹：每年一两次，他能帮一位老朋友看管房子。圣诞节前后，他得到了一个帮人看房超过两周的机会。那天结束时，我见到他吃午饭，他又回到了街头。我想知道终于能有一个舒适的地方睡觉对他来说是什么感觉。通常，他无法依赖任何固定的地点。有时，他必须在全家福（Kinko's）或唐恩都乐（Dunkin' Donuts）待上一整晚。
Sleep is such a large part of the whole experience of being homeless. I should say sleeplessness. You never get enough sleep. You're so tired so much of the time.
睡觉是无家可归体验的一大部分。我应该说是失眠。你永远睡不够。你大部分时间都太累了。
(INTERVIEWER) CHELSEA MERZ: So what was it like your first night indoors? What was it like to sleep?
（采访者）切尔西·默兹：那你第一天待在室内是什么感觉？睡觉是什么感觉？
(SUBJECT) MATTHEW: The first night is the best, because you know you've got 16 consecutive nights of uninterrupted living indoors again, of being able to come over to this apartment, open the door, unlock it with a key, open the door, go over to the sofa, this nice, huge, comfortable, soft sofa with eight large pillows in front of the TV set, with a remote control and everything. It's like what Jean Valjean experienced in the 1935 version of the film Les Miserables with Fredric March as Jean Valjean. After all those years in the prison, or the galley slave prison system, whatever, he's released finally. I think it's 14 years or something in which he was sleeping on hard surfaces. And when he's finally shown the room where he's going to get to stay when it's time for him to go to sleep, he looks at the bed.
（受访者）马修：第一天是最棒的，因为你知道你又有了连续16天不间断的室内生活，能来到这个公寓，打开门，用钥匙锁上，打开门，走到沙发那儿，这个又好、又大、又舒适、又柔软，电视机前有八个大枕头，有遥控器之类的。就像让·瓦尔让在1935年电影版《悲惨世界》（Fredric March主演）中所经历的那样。在那所有的监狱系统生活了那么多年之后，他终于被释放了。我想大概是14年左右，他一直睡在坚硬的表面上。当他最终被带到睡觉的房间时，他看着那张床。
And in the years before I was homeless, whenever I'd see this film, I never noticed this. He's looking at the bed. And that bed, it's like it's a soft surface, a soft mattress. It's a bed. He hasn't slept in a bed for like 14 years. And when he plops down in it, he leans back, and he stretches out. If I remember correctly, his eyes close, as he's savoring the comfort.
在流落街头之前，每当我看到这部电影，我都没注意到这一点。他在看那张床。那张床，就像是柔软的表面，软床垫。那是一张床。他大概有14年没睡在床上了。当他倒在上面时，他向后靠，伸展开来。如果我没记错的话，当他品味那份舒适时，他的眼睛闭上了。
That's what it's like. That's what it feels like. That's what it felt like the first night I was in there for these 16 nights in a row.
就是那种感觉。就是那种滋味。这就是我连续在这待的16天里的第一晚的感觉。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Matthew has been on the streets of Boston for seven years. This was an excerpt from an ongoing radio project Chelsea Merz and Matthew are working on. Coming up, which is more dangerous to your health-- heart disease, or your own family? Answers in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
（主持人）艾拉·格拉斯：马修已经在波士顿街头流落了七年。这是切尔西·默兹和马修正在进行的一个电台项目节选。即将到来的是，对你的健康更危险的是什么——心脏病，还是你自己的家人？从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司那里，在我们的节目继续时，一分钟后揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week in our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, stories of giving things up, living without, voluntarily or not. We've arrived at Act Four of our program. Act Four, Tin Man. Sometimes you give up something, and you're not sure if it's your own idea or not, as in this next story, a short story by Judy Budnitz, read for us by actor Matt Malloy.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都会在节目中选择一个主题，为你带来各种关于这个主题的故事。今天的节目，是关于放弃某些东西、没有那些东西生活的故事，无论是自愿还是被迫。我们已经到了节目的第四幕。第四幕，铁皮人。有时你放弃了某些东西，而且不确定这是不是你自己的主意，就像接下来这个故事，朱迪·布德尼茨的一个短篇小说，由演员马特·马洛伊为我们朗读。
(HOST) MATT MALLOY: "What kind of son are you," asks Aunt Fran. Aunt Nina says, "Your own flesh and blood. What your mother wouldn't do for you." Aunt Fran goes on, "She'd do anything for you, anything in the world. And now you won't give just a little back." "For shame," says Aunt Nina. The heat is stifling, but she pulls her sweater closer.
（主持人）马特·马洛伊：“你是个什么样的儿子，”弗兰姨妈问。妮娜姨妈说，“你自己的骨肉。你母亲为你做什么都不会过分。”弗兰姨妈继续说，“她会为你做任何事，世界上任何事。而现在你连一点点回馈都不愿意给。”“真丢脸，”妮娜姨妈说。天气闷热，但她把毛衣拉得更紧了。
We're sitting in the hospital waiting room, Aunt Fran and Aunt Nina and I. My mother suffered a heart attack this morning. We're waiting to see her, the aunts and I. The doctor told us her heart won't last much longer.
我们坐在医院候诊室，弗兰姨妈、妮娜姨妈和我。我母亲今天早上心脏病发作了。我们正等着见她，我和姨妈们。医生告诉我们她的心脏撑不了多久了。
"We can't fix it," the doctor said. "She needs a new one, a transplant." "Well then, give her one," the aunts cried. "It's not that easy," said the doctors. "We need a doctor." The doctors went away. The aunts looked at me.
“我们修不好，”医生说。“她需要一颗新的，做移植。”“那就给她一颗，”姨妈们大喊。“没那么简单，”医生们说。“我们需要一位捐赠者。”医生们走了。姨妈们看着我。
"Arnie," Nina said. "What about your heart?" "My heart," I shouted. "Are you crazy?" That started them both off on what a bad son I was. It's impossible to argue with Nina, especially with Fran to back her up.
“阿尼，”妮娜说，“你的心脏呢？”“我的心脏，”我大叫。“你们疯了吗？”这让她们俩都开始指责我是个坏儿子。跟妮娜争论是不可能的，尤其是还有弗兰在后面支持她的时候。
I sit in the middle. Aunt Fran clutches one arm, Aunt Nina the other. They wept at first, but now they sit grimly. A Styrofoam cup of coffee steams next to my foot, but I can't reach for it. The aunts don't care. They're amazed that I bought it, amazed that I could even think of coffee at a time like this.
我坐在中间。弗兰姨妈抓住一只胳膊，妮娜姨妈抓住另一只。她们起初在哭，但现在坐得很严肃。我脚边的一杯泡沫塑料杯咖啡在冒着热气，但我够不到。姨妈们不在乎。她们很惊讶我竟然买了它，惊讶在这种时候我竟然还能想到咖啡。
Aunt Fran wears a bally sweater and sensible shoes. Her lips are pressed tight. She taps her feet nervously. On my other side, Nina licks her lips, again and again.
弗兰姨妈穿着一件毛衣，穿着舒适的鞋子。她的嘴唇紧闭。她紧张地拍着脚。在我另一边，妮娜一次又一次地舔着嘴唇。
"I saw it on 60 Minutes," Aunt Fran announces. "They put the heart in a cooler, a regular Igloo cooler like we have at home. And they rush it in a helicopter to the hospital. And they put it in, connect up the pipes. It's just like plumbing."
“我在《60分钟》节目上看到过，”弗兰姨妈宣布，“他们把心脏放进冷却器里，就像我们家里那种普通的冷藏箱。然后他们用直升机把它送到医院。他们把它放进去，接上管道。这就像管道维修一样。”
"You must be your mother's tissue type, too. I'm sure you are," Aunt Nina puts in. "You're young. You're strong. You have a college education. Your heart is exactly what she needs."
“你一定也是你母亲的组织类型。我相信你是，”妮娜姨妈插话说，“你年轻，你强壮。你受过大学教育。你的心脏正是她所需要的。”
"You shouldn't have started smoking, though," Aunt Fran goes on. "It's so bad for the heart. You should have thought of that when you started."
“不过你不该开始抽烟的，”弗兰姨妈继续说，“这对心脏太坏了。你开始抽烟的时候就该想到这点。”
"But what about me," I blurt out finally. "That's what we're talking about. We're talking about your heart," Nina says. "But what happens to me?" I say again. "I can't believe he's thinking of himself at a time like this," Aunt Fran sniffs.
“但我呢，”我终于脱口而出。“我们在谈论的就是这个。我们在谈论你的心脏，”妮娜说。“但我怎么办？”我再次说。“真不敢相信他在这种时候还在为自己着想，”弗兰姨妈嗤之以鼻。
"I need my heart. You want me to die so my mother can live?" "Of course we don't want that," says Aunt Fran. "Sylvie loves you so much. She'd want to die herself if you died."
“我需要我的心脏。你们想让我死来让我母亲活吗？”“我们当然不想那样，”弗兰姨妈说，“西尔维那么爱你。如果你死了，她自己也会想死的。”
"We can't both have my heart," I say. "Of course not," says Nina. "You can get one of those monkey hearts, or that artificial heart they made such a fuss about in the news a while back." "Why can't mother get one of those, or a transplant from someone else?" "Do you want your mother should have a stranger's heart, or a monkey's heart? Your poor mother. Do you remember how she never used to take you to the zoo, because she couldn't stand to see the filthy monkeys? And you want her to have a monkey's heart? It would kill her," Fran cries.
“我们不能共用我的心脏，”我说。“当然不能，”妮娜说，“你可以弄一颗猴心，或者新闻上大吵大闹过的那种人造心脏。”“为什么母亲不能要那些，或者移植别人的？”“你难道想让你母亲用陌生人的心，或者猴子的心吗？你可怜的母亲。你还记得她从不带你去动物园吗，因为她受不了看那些肮脏的猴子？你想让她有一颗猴子的心？那会害死她的，”弗兰大喊。
"She's so weak. She needs a heart that will agree with her," Aunt Nina adds. "Any heart but yours wouldn't, just wouldn't do. But you, you can handle anything. You're young. You're strong. You--" "--have a college education," I finish for her. Aunt Nina glares and says, "Your mother worked herself to the bone for you, so you could go to college and make something of yourself. And now what do you do? Out of college four years already, all you do is sit in front of a typewriter all day, call yourself a writer, smoking those cigarettes, never get a haircut."
“她太虚弱了。她需要一颗跟她契合的心，”妮娜姨妈补充道，“任何心除了你的都不行，就是不行。但你，你可以处理任何事。你年轻。你强壮。你——” “——受过大学教育，”我替她说完了。妮娜姨妈怒视着说，“你母亲为你累死累活，好让你上大学，有所成就。而现在你做什么？大学毕业四年了，整天就知道坐在打字机前，自称作家，抽那些香烟，从不理发。”
"And the first time your mother needs you," Aunt Fran finishes, "you turn your back on her." They both tighten their grips on my arm. "I do things for Mother all the time," I begin.
“你母亲第一次需要你时，”弗兰姨妈总结道，“你就背弃了她。”她们俩抓我胳膊的手更紧了，“我一直在为母亲做事情，”我开始说。
One of the doctors appears at the end of the hall. As he approaches, my aunts rise, pulling me with them. "Is she all right?" Demands Fran when he's still 20 feet away. "We've found a donor," Nina announces. The doctor greets us. He's a small man, completely bald. The eyes behind thick glasses are sad. He strokes his scalp as he talks, savoring the feel of it. "She's all right. She's being monitored," he says. "We will look for a donor, but there's a long waiting list."
一位医生出现在走廊尽头。当他走近时，姨妈们站了起来，拉着我一起。“她还好吗？”弗兰在他还离着20英尺远时就问道。“我们找到了捐赠者，”妮娜宣布。医生问候我们。他是个秃头的小个子。厚眼镜后的眼睛很忧伤。他边说话边抚摸着头皮，享受着那种感觉。“她还好。正在监护中，”他说，“我们会寻找捐赠者，但排队名单很长。”
"We've got a donor, Sylvie's son. He's in the prime of health," Aunt Nina says. "This is Arnie," Fran explains. The doctor studies me carefully.
“我们有捐赠者，西尔维的儿子。他正值壮年，”妮娜姨妈说。“这是阿尼，”弗兰解释说。医生仔细地打量我。
"Surely you don't do that sort of thing," I say incredulously. He gazes at me. "It's very rare, very rare indeed that a son will be so good as to donate his heart. In a few cases, it has been done, but it's so rare to find such a son, a rare and beautiful thing."
“你们肯定不会做那种事吧，”我难以置信地说。他凝视着我。“很难得，确实很难得有儿子愿意捐出心脏。在极少数情况下，有人做过，但很难找到这样的儿子，这是一件稀有而美好的事情。”
He takes off his glasses and polishes them on his sleeve. Without them, his eyes are small, piggish. He puts them back on, and his eyes are sad and soulful once more. "You must love your mother very much," he says. "Oh, he does," Fran says. I shift my feet and knock over the cup of coffee, and it spills on the floor, the sudden ugly brownness spreading over the empty white.
他摘下眼镜，在袖子上擦了擦。没有眼镜，他的眼睛很小，像猪一样。他戴回去，眼神又变得忧伤而充满深情。“你一定很爱你母亲，”他说。“哦，他爱，”弗兰说。我挪动脚，碰倒了咖啡杯，咖啡溅在地板上，难看的棕色瞬间在空旷的白色地板上蔓延开来。
A nurse leads us to the intensive care unit where my mother is lying attached to machines and bags of fluid. Aunt Fran rushes to one side of the bed, Aunt Nina the other. I shuffle awkwardly at the foot of the bed. I touch my mother's feet.
一名护士带我们去重症监护室，我母亲躺在那，连着机器和体液袋。弗兰姨妈冲到床的一边，妮娜姨妈冲到另一边。我局促地站在床尾。我摸了摸我母亲的脚。
"Sylvie, are you all right?" the aunts cry. My mother opens her eyes. There are purple circles around them. She looks pale, but not so different from usual, hardly on the verge of death. She smiles dully at her sisters. "Oh, Sylvie, you look wonderful, just the same," they say.
“西尔维，你还好吗？”姨妈们大喊。我母亲睁开眼睛。眼睛周围有紫色圆圈。她看起来很苍白，但跟平时没什么两样，一点也不像奄奄一息的样子。她呆滞地向姐妹们笑了笑。“哦，西尔维，你看起来太棒了，还是老样子，”她们说。
Then she raises her eyes to me. "Oh, Arnie, you look terrible," she says. "That jacket, I told you to throw it away. I'll find you another. There's no reason to go around looking like a mess." "Arnie has some good news," Nina says. "Then why does he look like a thundercloud?" says my mother. "Arnie, is something bothering you?"
然后她抬眼看着我。“哦，阿尼，你看起来太糟糕了，”她说，“那件夹克，我告诉过你把它扔掉。我会给你找另一件。没有理由把自己打扮成这副脏兮兮的样子。”“阿尼有好消息要说，”妮娜说。“那他为什么看起来像乌云密布？”我母亲说，“阿尼，有什么困扰你吗？”
Fran says, "Arnie wants to give you his heart." "I never said that," I cry. There's a pause. "Of course, Arnie, you shouldn't. You don't need to do that for me. Really, you don't," my mother says. She looks terribly sad. The aunts' faces have gone stony. "I never expected anything from you, you know, of course, nothing like this."
弗兰说，“阿尼想把他的心给你。”“我从来没说过，”我大叫。停顿了一下。“阿尼，你当然不该这样。你不需要为我做那种事。真的，你不用的，”我母亲说。她看起来极其悲伤。姨妈们的脸变僵硬了。“我从来没期待过你做什么，你知道的，当然，什么像这样的事都没期待过。”
I look down at her feet, two motionless humps under the blanket. "I'm considering it, Mother. Really, I am. I want to find out more about it before I decide, that's all. It's not as simple as changing a car battery or something." I force out a laugh. No one else laughs. But the aunts' faces melt a little.
我看着她的脚，毯子下两个一动不动的隆起。“我在考虑，母亲。真的。我只是想在决定前多了解一下。这不像换个汽车电池那么简单。”我强迫自己笑出声来。没别人笑。但姨妈们的脸部表情稍微缓和了一点。
My heart is pounding. My mother closes her eyes. "You're a good boy, Arnie," she says. "Your father would be proud."
我的心在狂跳。我母亲闭上眼睛。“你是个好孩子，阿尼，”她说，“你父亲会为你感到骄傲的。”
A nurse comes in and tells us that we should let my mother rest for a while. Aunt Fran and Aunt Nina head back to the waiting room. I walk up and down the halls of dull white, where patients shuffle in slow motion, wheeling their IVs along beside them. I can feel on the floor the buzzing vibration of motors churning away somewhere in the heart of the building.
一名护士进来告诉我们该让我母亲休息一会儿了。弗兰姨妈和妮娜姨妈回到候诊室。我在暗白色的走廊里走来走去，病人们慢动作地挪动着，推着他们的输液架在身边。我能感觉到地板上有某种建筑心脏部位的马达在嗡嗡作响。
I take the elevator and wander until I find a pay phone. I call up Mandy. She picks up on the first ring.
我坐电梯到处转，直到找到一部公用电话。我给曼迪打了电话。她第一声就接了。
"Hi," she says. "Where have you been?" "My mother had a heart attack this morning," I say. "I'm at the hospital." "Oh, I knew this would happen," Mandy says. "I burned my hand on the radiator this morning, and right away, I thought, uh-oh, an omen. Something bad's going to happen. How old's your mother?" "57," I say. "Oh, that's young for a heart attack. And she wasn't fat or anything. I feel like it's my fault. I should have warned you or something."
“嗨，”她说，“你跑哪去了？”“我母亲今天早上心脏病发作了，”我说，“我在医院。”“哦，我知道会发生这种事，”曼迪说，“我今天早上被散热器烫伤了手，立刻就想，糟了，这是凶兆。会有坏事发生。你母亲多大？”“57岁，”我说。“哦，对心脏病来说太年轻了。她又不胖之类的。我觉得是我的错。我本该提醒你什么的。”
Finally, I ask her to come to the hospital, and she says, all right, and hangs up. I don't need to tell her where to go. Mandy never gets lost. She never has to wait in line. Strangers on the street talk to her. Jobs fall in her lap.
最后，我让她来医院，她说，好的，然后挂断了电话。我不需要告诉她去哪里。曼迪从来不会迷路。她从来不用排队。街上的陌生人都会跟她说话。工作会自己掉到她身上。
She's nice-looking, freckles on her nose, good, straight teeth. She keeps telling me that my signs indicate my life will be on a big upswing soon, and that I'm just in a transition period right now. I hope she's right.
她长得好看，鼻子上有雀斑，牙齿整齐。她一直告诉我我的迹象表明生活很快就会好转，我现在正处于过渡期。希望她是对的。
I finally reach the lobby. And just as I do, Mandy comes bursting in the doors, beaming at me. She doesn't smile. She beams. "I knew I'd find you," she says. "How's your mother? Have you seen her?" Her breath in my face is like pine trees and toothpaste.
我终于到了大厅。就在这时，曼迪冲了进来，对着我发光。她不是在笑。她在发光。“我就知道能找到你，”她说，“你母亲怎么样？见过她了吗？”她喷在我脸上的气息像松树和牙膏。
"Yeah, she's all right for now. Come on. Let's go outside for a minute. I want to ask you something."
“嗯，暂时还行。来吧。我们去外面待一会儿。我想问你一件事。”
Outside, the afternoon is darkening to early evening. We wander in the parking lot among the cars, talking softly, like we're afraid we'll wake them. It's cold. I keep looking back to see if anyone's following us.
外面，下午正变暗为傍晚。我们在停车场穿梭在车子之间，轻声交谈，仿佛怕吵醒它们。天很冷。我不停地回头看是否有人跟着我们。
"They say my mother's heart is bad, I tell Mandy. She needs a new one. They want me to donate my heart. What do you think of that?"
“他们说我母亲的心脏不好，”我告诉曼迪，“她需要一颗新的。他们想让我捐出心脏。你怎么看？”
Mandy stops, her eyes and mouth open. Wind whips her frizzy hair around her face. She looks shocked. I breathe a sigh of relief at last, someone who can see reason. But then she says, "Oh, Arnie, how wonderful. Can they really do that? That's so wonderful, congratulations."
曼迪停下来，嘴巴和眼睛都张开了。风吹动她毛躁的头发遮住脸。她看起来很震惊。我终于松了口气，终于有人能认清现实了。但她却说，“哦，阿尼，太棒了。他们真的能做到吗？那太棒了，恭喜你。”
"You mean you think I should do it?" "Isn't technology incredible?" Mandy says. "These days, doctors can do anything. Now you can share yourself, really give yourself to someone in ways you never even thought were possible before. Your mother must be thrilled."
“你是说你认为我应该这样做？”“技术难道不不可思议吗？”曼迪说，“这些天，医生们无所不能。现在你可以分享你自己，真正地以你以前从未想过的方式把自己交给某人。你母亲一定很激动。”
"But it's crazy," I say. She takes my hand in hers and looks up into my eyes. "Frankly, Arnie, I didn't think you had it in you. I'm really impressed, really, I am."
“但这很疯狂，”我说。她抓住我的手，抬头看着我的眼睛。“坦白说，阿尼，我没想到你有这个胆量。我真的印象深刻，真的。”
"Mandy, I thought you could be realistic about this. What about me? Do you want me dead? What am I supposed to do without a heart?"
“曼迪，我以为你能现实点。那我呢？你想让我死吗？没有心脏我该怎么办？”
"Oh, I'm sure they could fix you up. The important thing right now is to help your mother." She unzips my jacket and presses her hand against my chest. My heart twitches, flutters like a baby bird in her hands.
“哦，我肯定他们能修复你。现在重要的是帮助你母亲。”她拉开我的夹克，把手按在我的胸口。我的心抽搐了一下，像她手中的小鸟一样扑腾。
"Arnie, you know what the right thing to do is. You should get back to your mother now." I watched her go. brisk, determined steps like a schoolteacher.
“阿尼，你知道该怎么做。你现在应该回到你母亲身边了。”我看着她走开。步伐轻快、果断，就像一位小学老师。
I find my way back to the waiting room. Someone's mopped up the coffee. "Feel better?" Nina asks. "Made a decision yet?" Fran says. "Yes. No. I don't know," I say. They are both quiet.
我回到候诊室。有人擦掉了咖啡。“感觉好点了吗？”妮娜问。“决定好了吗？”弗兰说。“是。不。我不知道，”我说。她们俩都很安静。
Fran turns to me. "Arnie, think about this. The heart's a little thing, really, less than a pound. It's just a muscle. You've got muscles all over the place. Can't you spare one?" She looks earnestly into my face. "Can't you spare a little bit of flesh?" And then they are crying, both of them, drops sliding down the wrinkles in their faces.
弗兰转向我。“阿尼，想想看。心脏是个小东西，真的，不到一磅。它只是块肌肉。你身上到处都是肌肉。难道不能分一点出来吗？”她真诚地盯着我的脸，“难道不能贡献一点点血肉吗？”然后她们开始哭，两个人都哭了，泪水顺着她们脸上的皱纹滑落。
Later, we go visit my mother again. She looks worse, but perhaps it's the fluorescent lights. I stand again at the foot of her bed. I can see the veins and tendons on her neck, so delicate, so close to the surface you could snip them with scissors. "Arnie," she says softly, "you should go home and get some sleep. And shave, you look terrible, so tired. Go. I'll be here tomorrow. I'm not going anywhere."
后来，我们又去探望了母亲。她看起来更糟了，但也许是因为荧光灯的缘故。我再次站在床尾。我能看到她脖子上的血管和筋腱，那么脆弱，离表面那么近，你可以用剪刀剪断它们。“阿尼，”她轻声说，“你该回家睡一觉。刮刮胡子，你看起来糟透了，太累了。去吧。我明天还在。我哪儿也不去。”
I drive home in the dark. I go up to my apartment and turn on the lights. I want to call Mandy. Then I realize I don't want to call her at all. Usually, my mother calls in the evening and tells me about TV programs and weather changes.
我在黑暗中开车回家。我走进公寓，打开灯。我想给曼迪打电话。然后我意识到我根本不想给她打电话。通常，我母亲会在晚上打来，跟我聊电视节目和天气变化。
I turn off the lights and sit in the dark. I look at the ceiling, at the smoke detector. It has a blue light that pulses with a regular beat, like the blip on a cardiograph.
我关掉灯，坐在黑暗中。看着天花板，看着烟雾探测器。它有一个蓝色的光，有规律地闪烁，就像心电图上的跳动。
Early the next morning at the hospital, I tell the doctor, "I want to do it. Give her my heart." He gives me a long, steady look, eyes huge behind the glasses. "I think you've made the right decision. I do," he says. His eyes drop to my chest. "We can get started right away."
第二天清晨在医院，我告诉医生，“我想做。给她我的心。”他盯着我看了一会儿，眼镜后的眼睛很大。“我想你做了正确的决定。确实，”他说。他的眼睛下移到我的胸口。“我们马上可以开始。”
"But what about the transplant for me?" I say. "Don't you need to arrange that first?" "Oh, we'll take care of that when the time comes. I want to get your heart into your mother right away, before, before--"
“但我怎么办？移植的问题呢？”我说，“难道不应该先安排那个吗？”“哦，到时候我们会处理的。我想尽快把你的心换给你母亲，在，在——”
"Before I change my mind?" I say. He hardly hears. He's already deep in his plans.
“在我改变主意之前？”我说。他几乎没听见。他已经深陷在计划中了。
He claps me on the back. "Have you told your mother yet? Well, go tell her. Then we'll get your chest shaved and get started."
他拍了拍我的背。“你告诉母亲了吗？好吧，去告诉她吧。然后我们剃掉你胸部的毛就开始。”
This is what I've realized. All along, I thought I'd publish a book, lots of books, get recognition, earn lots of money, support my mother in style in her old age, give her gorgeous grandchildren. I thought that was the way to pay her back for everything I owe her. But now, it looks like I have to pay my debts with my heart instead. Under these circumstances, I don't have a choice.
这就是我意识到的。一直以来，我以为我会出版一本书，很多书，获得认可，赚很多钱，以体面的方式供养年迈的母亲，给她生出漂亮孙子。我以为那是报答我欠她一切的方式。但现在看来，我必须用我的心来偿还债务。在这种情况下，我别无选择。
I'm almost glad. It seems easier this way. I'll just give her a piece of muscle, and then I'll be free of her forever, all my debts paid. One quick operation will be so much easier than struggling for the rest of my life to do back to her all the things she thinks she's done for me. It seems like a good bargain.
我几乎感到高兴。这样似乎更容易。我只是给她一块肌肉，然后我就永远摆脱她了，我所有的债都还清了。一次快速的手术比我余生还要辛苦地去回报她那些认为她为你所做的一切要容易得多。这看起来是个不错的交易。
When I tell my mother the news, she cries a little and smiles and says, "Oh, I didn't expect it. Oh, not for a minute. I wouldn't expect such a sacrifice from you, Arnie. I wouldn't dare to even mention such a thing. It's more than any mother could expect of her son. I'm so proud of you. I guess I did a good job of raising you after all. You've turned into such a fine, good person. I worried that I may have made mistakes when I was bringing you up, but now I know I didn't."
当我告诉母亲这个消息时，她哭了一点点，微笑着说，“哦，我没指望。哦，一点都没指望。我没指望你做出这种牺牲，阿尼。我甚至不敢提这件事。这比任何母亲所能期待的还要多。我为你感到自豪。看来我确实把你教育得很好。你已经成长为一个如此优秀的人。我曾担心在抚养你时犯了错，但现在我知道我没犯。”
On and on she goes. And the aunts, they cry and clutch my arms, not so tight as before. And they say they doubted me, but they never will again. What a good son, they keep saying. Looking at them now, they seem smaller than they did before, shriveled.
她没完没了地说。姨妈们哭着抓住我的胳膊，没有之前那么紧了。她们说她们曾怀疑过我，但以后再也不会了。真是个好儿子，她们不停地说。现在看着她们，她们看起来比以前小了，萎缩了。
I call Mandy, and she dashes over to the hospital. She kisses all over my face with her cherry-flavored Chapstick. She hugs me and presses her ear against my chest. She tells me she knew I'd do the right thing.
我给曼迪打电话，她冲到医院。她用樱桃味的润唇膏吻遍我的脸。她拥抱我，把耳朵贴在我的胸口。她告诉我她知道我会做正确的事。
I'm feeling pretty good now. I light up a cigarette. She takes it away from and mashes it beneath her heel. "That belongs to your mother now," she says.
我感觉好多了。我点了一支烟。她把它拿走，在脚底碾碎。“那现在是你母亲的了，”她说。
They all give me flowers. I feel like a hero. I kiss my mother's cheek. I hop on a stretcher. They wheel me out. They sedate me slightly, strip me, shave me. And then they put the mask on and knock me out good.
她们都给我花。我觉得自己像个英雄。我亲了母亲的脸颊。我跳上担架。她们把我推出去。她们给我做了轻微的镇静，脱掉我的衣服，剃了毛。然后她们戴上口罩，把我彻底麻醉过去。
It's like I'm falling, falling down a deep well. And the circle of daylight above me grows smaller and smaller and smaller, until it is a tiny white bird swooping and fluttering against a vast night sky. How does it feel to have no heart? It feels light, hollow, rattly. Something huge is missing. It leaves an ache, like the ghost of a severed limb. I'm so light inside, but so heavy on the outside, like gravity increased a hundredfold, gravity holding me to the bed like the ropes and pegs of a thousand Lilliputians.
感觉像是在坠落，坠入一口深井。我头顶的光圈越来越小，直到它变成一只 tiny 的白鸟，在辽阔的夜空中扑腾。没有心是什么感觉？感觉很轻，空荡荡的，嘎嘎作响。某种巨大的东西不见了。它留下了一种痛感，就像截肢后的幻肢。我内在很轻，但外在很重，仿佛重力增加了百倍，重力像绑着成千上万个小人国人的绳索和桩子一样把我固定在床上。
I lie at the bottom of a pool. Up above, I see the light on the surface. It wavers, ripples, breaks, and comes together again.
我躺在池底。上方，我看到水面的光。它波动、涟漪、破碎，又汇聚在一起。
I can see the people moving about far above in the light. I am down here in the dark, cradled in the algae. Curious fish nibble my eyelashes.
我能看到人们在遥远的光亮中走动。我在这黑暗中，蜷缩在藻类里。好奇的鱼儿啃咬我的睫毛。
After a while, I see a smooth, pink face above me. The doctor? "Arnie," he says, "the operation went very well. Your mother's doing wonderfully. She loves the new heart." His words begin far away and drift closer, growing louder and louder until they plunk down next to me like pebbles.
过了一会儿，我看到上方有一张光滑的粉红色的脸。医生？“阿尼，”他说，“手术非常成功。你母亲做得棒极了。她喜欢那颗新心。”他的话开始很遥远，慢慢飘近，声音越来越响，直到像石子一样落在我的身边。
"Arnie," he calls. The pool's surface shivers. His face balloons, shrinks to a dot, then unfolds itself. "Arnie, about you. We're having a little trouble. There's a shortage of spare hearts in the country right now. We're looking for some kind of replacement. But don't worry. You'll be fine."
“阿尼，”他喊道。池面颤抖。他的脸膨胀、缩小成一个点，然后展开。“阿尼，关于你。我们遇到点麻烦。全国目前 spare 心脏短缺。我们正在寻找替代品。但别担心。你会没事的。”
Later, I see Aunt Fran and Aunt Nina. They lean close. They're huge. Their faces bleed and run together like wet watercolors. "Your mother's doing so well," they call. "She loves you. Oh, she's so excited. She'll be in to see you soon."
后来，我看到了弗兰姨妈和妮娜姨妈。她们凑得很近。她们巨大无比。她们的脸流血，像湿水彩一样融合在一起。“你母亲做得很好，”她们喊道，“她爱你。哦，她很兴奋。她很快就会来看你的。”
And later, it's my mother gliding in, her face pink, her hair curled. "Arnie, Arnie, you good boy," she calls. And then they wheel her out.
后来，母亲滑进来了，脸是粉色的，头发卷卷的。“阿尼，阿尼，好孩子，”她喊道。然后她们把她推了出去。
They leave me alone for a long time. I lie in the deep. It sways me like a hammock. There is a deep, low humming all around, like whales moaning.
她们留我一个人待了很久。我躺在深渊里。它像吊床一样晃动我。周围有一种深沉、低沉的嗡嗡声，像鲸鱼在呻吟。
My mother does not visit again. Alone in the dark, no footsteps, no click of the light switch. Then a doctor looms above me. "Your mother," he says, "is not doing well. The heart does not fit as well as we thought. It's a bit too small." He turns away and leans over again. "As for you, we're working on it. There's nothing available at the moment. But don't you worry."
我母亲没再来过。在黑暗中孤独一人，没有脚步声，没有电灯开关的咔哒声。然后一位医生在我上方隐现。“你母亲，”他说，“做得不好。这颗心不像我们想的那样合适。它太小了。”他转过身又弯下腰。“至于你，我们正在想办法。目前没有可用的。但你别担心。”
And then Fran and Nina are back. "How could you?" they scream, their voices shattering the surface into fragments. "Giving your mother a bad heart. How could you? What kind of son are you? She's dying. Your mother's dying, all because of you." They weep together.
然后弗兰和妮娜又回来了。“你怎么能这样？”她们尖叫，声音把水面击碎成碎片，“给你母亲一颗坏心。你怎么能这样？你是个什么样的儿子？她快死了。你母亲快死了，全都是因为你。”她们一起哭泣。
For a long time, no one comes. I know without anyone telling me that my mother is dead. It is my heart. When it ceases to beat, I know.
很长一段时间没人来。我不用别人说也知道我母亲死了。那是我的心。当它停止跳动时，我就知道了。
The doctor comes to tell me how sorry he is. "She was doing so well at first, but then it turned out the heart just wasn't enough. I tell you, though, she was thinking of you when she died. She asked for you."
医生来告诉我他有多抱歉。“她起初做得很好，但后来证明这颗心根本不够。我告诉你，她死的时候心里想着你。她找过你。”
He sits quietly for a moment. "we haven't managed to find a heart for you. But you'll be fine. We've shot you up full of preservatives. You'll stay fresh for a while yet." He goes away.
他安静地坐了一会儿。“我们没能为你找到一颗心。但你会没事的。我们给你注射了防腐剂。你会保持新鲜一阵子。”他走了。
Aunt Fran and Aunt Nina no longer visit. Mandy? Gone. I lie listening to the emptiness in my chest like wind wailing through canyons. These days, the doctor comes in often to chat with me.
弗兰姨妈和妮娜姨妈不再探望。曼迪？走了。我躺在那里，听着胸口里的空虚，就像风在峡谷中哀号。这些日子，医生经常进来跟我闲聊。
One day, he tells me a story. "You know, when your mother died, we managed to save your heart. It was still healthy. We thought about giving it back to you, but there was this little girl here, about eight years old. She needed a new heart, too. Cute little blonde girl. One time a basketball star came in here to visit, and there were TV cameras and photographers and everything. She was in the papers a lot. Kids were always sending her cards.
有一天，他讲了一个故事。“你知道，你母亲去世时，我们成功保留了你的心。它依然健康。我们想过把它还给你，但这里有个小女孩，大概八岁。她也需要一颗新心。可爱的金发小女孩。有一次篮球明星进来探望，这里全是电视摄像机、摄影师之类的。她经常出现在报纸上。孩子们总是给她寄卡片。
"Anyway, we decided to give her your heart. She's only a kid, after all. She's got her whole life ahead of her. Why should we deny her that? I'm sure your mother would have wanted it that way. She was such a caring, selfless woman. I'm sure, deep down, you want her to have it too, don't you?" "Of course I do."
“总之，我们决定给她你的心。毕竟她只是个孩子。她余生还长。我们为什么要剥夺她的这一切？我相信你母亲也会希望这样。她是一个如此富有爱心、无私的女性。我肯定，内心深处，你也希望她拥有它，不是吗？”“我当然希望。”
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Judy Budnitz's short story, "Guilt," from her third collection of short stories called Flying Leap . Her third book, Nice Big American Baby , was published last year. Her story was read for us by actor Matt Malloy, who is in too many movies to possibly named here.
（主持人）艾拉·格拉斯：朱迪·布德尼茨的短篇小说，“内疚”，出自她第三部短篇小说集《飞跃》。她的第三本书，《可爱的美国大宝宝》，于去年出版。她的故事由演员马特·马洛伊朗读，他出演的电影太多，无法在这里一一列举。
Well, our program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Starlee Kine, and Sarah Koenig. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Sam Hallgren, Todd Bachmann, and Thea Chaloner. Chelsea Merz's story with Matthew came to us with help from Jay Allison and the Cape and Islands NPR stations, with support from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
好了，我们的节目今天由黛安·库克和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、斯塔莉·凯恩和莎拉·柯尼希。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责运营我们的网站。制作帮助来自萨姆·霍尔格伦、托德·巴赫曼和西娅·查洛纳。切尔西·默兹与马修的故事得益于杰·艾利森和海角与岛屿（Cape and Islands）NPR电台的帮助，并得到了公共广播公司的支持。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
（鸣谢）
Our web site, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our shows for absolutely free or buy CDs of them. Or you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目，或者购买CD。或者你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司（PRI）分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助名录）
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Tory Malatia. Our message to him?
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。我们给他的信息是？
(HOST) MATT MALLOY: We've shot you up full of preservatives. You'll stay fresh for a while yet.
（主持人）马特·马洛伊：我们给你注射了防腐剂。你会保持新鲜一阵子。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: I'm I'ra Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
（主持人）艾拉·格拉斯：我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再回来分享更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。